okay uh well good afternoon everybody
and
uh welcome to this last
of the open simon's lecture for this for
this semester
um so um
let's see uh it's it gives me great
pleasure to uh
to introduce ignacio sirach who
most of you know is the co-organizer of
this special semester on
on quantum hamiltonian complexity
many of you also probably know you are
in for a special treat
uh um ignacio is one of the very
few people who is equally fluent
talking to experimental ammo physicists
as he is to
theoretical condensed metaphysicists and
as many of you have discovered
as he is to talk in talking to
theoretical computer scientists
so uh ignacio is the currently the
director of the max blank institute in
carting
germany and uh he
he's responsible for just a remarkable
number of innovations
uh starting with his proposal for iron
trap quantum computing which which
really got
some of the experimental work off the
ground uh
also his work on on on optical lattices
and then
of course on on the theoretical side in
condensed matter physics he's he's done
his remarkable range of work you know
on on peps and renormalization groups
and so on
and i i should say i should say that
ignacio is a you know i'm sure you some
some of you who've interacted with him
might not have realized exactly how
distinguished he is he's received a
number of awards including
including the benjamin franklin medal in
2010
and the wolf prize last year which um
people who know more about this than i
do uh say
is there is um is is um
well correlated with people who
eventually want to win a nobel prize
so um so um so i should say that his
uh you know probably is his level of
distinction is only
only surpassed by his uh his humility
and his uh
his enthusiasm in going for a beer after
after
so it's a great pleasure to be here and
so first of all i would like to thank
the
simon center for hosting not only me but
also many
people coming from a physics background
and computer science background
to participate in the program called
quantum hamiltonian complexity that is
finishing next week or in a couple of
weeks from now
and second i would also like to thank
the middle institute for isis
basic research in science for uh
sponsoring my stay here
and so i was asked already many many uh
months ago to give a kind of a popular
talk
about the content of this program
quantum hematology and complexity took
part it is taking part
in in this institute at this moment so
this is going to be very
a very low level so i'm sorry because i
see that some of the participants of the
workshop are here so for them because
this would be
embarrassing for me to tell in front of
them something like that but anyways i
have
i want to explain uh what are the
motivations so why are we having this
workshop and so what are the questions
that we're trying to address and and
and so what do we know what's what what
is known what's not known
and it would be very hand waving and so
only at the end i think that i will go
into a little bit of detail and i'll
introduce maybe some concepts and some
formulas and
and so on but i hope that people are not
specialized
uh can follow all the all the talk and
and i also assume that you have no idea
about quantum mechanics i will use a
very
a very kind of conveying way of of uh
talking about quantum mechanics so again
i have to apologize in front of the
people who are expressed in quantum
mechanics because some of the things
that i'm going to say i mean that's not
really rewards but it's a way of
explaining
if i have to tell somebody who has not
had this experience of quantum mechanics
before
so uh so in the title uh i wrote
quantum manual system but also the word
of simulate and so what i mean is
something that is sometimes puzzling
people like like me and some other
people
is that now you want to construct a
plane
or you want to make a big building you
can do it basically on your computer
okay so you can test whether the plane
or most parts of the plane will fly
just by writing a program with computer
finite elements testing everything
and and then you have to do a couple of
experiments just to check a couple of
things but you can basically
simulate so how this plane with some
given profile et cetera et cetera will
behave
in a in a computer you don't have to
test it you don't have to to
to build it and see if it flies or not i
mean you can you can
do it in your computer and the same
thing with a building however there are
some materials like this one that is
here which is a very
very small is maybe i mean two
centimeters long
and that's that you it's a super
conducting material that you put
in other non in a current in the
magnetic field and then it levitates
and we don't know how to describe this
material here and not only that
i can give you other materials which are
composed of only
100 or thousands of atoms and we don't
know how to describe we don't know how
to
how to predict what are the physical
properties we don't know if it will
levitate or will not levitate in the
presence of a magnetic field
or if it will be conductor or not
conduct or if it's conductor is a good
conductor superconductor or not
superconductor
so it's a fascinating the fact that we
can simulate microscopic things things
that are made out of many many many
atoms and and
what is things that are microscopic that
very few components
we cannot we cannot simulate and have no
idea how to do this and so
why what i want to explain here is why
this is so difficult
and so some ways of what i mean also by
difficult and also to some ways around
so what are people trying to do in order
to
attack these problems because some of
them are very relevant so for example
this material here
the superconducting material if we would
understand so why is it
superconductor and would be able to
increase the temperature at which
it becomes superconductor then this
would have a
it would be a revolution in in
technology that could
have trains i don't know that that
that that levitate and then have less
friction
or we could store electricity during
night just going around without losses
and and then use it during the day so it
will have a very big impact but we don't
we cannot do that and one of the reasons
because we don't know how to describe
these materials anyway so so and
i'm a physicist and so with typically
when you have a physical system like the
material that i had before
what we do is to do models of that so
for example you have a
piece of material or you have i don't
know
like in experiments here in in berkeley
in the physics department they have
atoms
that are levitating in space and they
are moving and they want to describe
what the physics or you have a molecules
and you want to describe what is the
reaction what would be the products of a
molecule
or even from a more fundamental point of
view you have something like the
standard model
these are uh some physical would you
want to discuss some physical systems
and so typically
you're interested in knowing some
properties of all of them so for example
what are the microscopic properties so
as i mentioned before is this conducting
not contacting
at least are these particles moving
freely or they will get stuck and they
cannot go
through each other or is there a
physical reaction here and can you have
products or not
you can also start want to study things
like stability so i mean if we touch
this material will it break down
or will something happen with that we
would like to know also
type of excitations of the the
probability of certain events of this
physical reaction of course or that
i mean in in the higgs boson is produced
et cetera et cetera so we have some
physical systems and ideas would like to
make
some predictions with that and in order
to do that what we do is to create
models so we take for example
into each of those physical systems and
we put them on a lattice
for instance we have a material the
material is composed of atoms which are
in a periodic structure and so they have
already a lattice structure and we study
the motion of the electrons on this
lattice then we have a lattice so we
have some lattice sides
and we model the electrons like being in
one position and jumping to the next one
to the next one to the next one or
if these electrons for example we're
interested not
in the electrical properties not whether
the electrons move there
but in the magnetic properties as you
know the electrons have a spin so which
is responsible like a small magnet which
is responsible
for the magnetic properties so we may be
interested now
in the whether this is a magnet or it's
not a magnet so then we just
write a lattice make a model of lattice
and we should put the magnet at each of
the sides
and then we study this this model here
or the same thing
in optical attitude the same thing with
chemistry so you also model it also i
mean discretizing maybe in a different
way or it probably
worked for the standard model also then
you dispense you put in some lattice
and then all you need to know in order
to discard these systems are what are
the interactions
between the different lapis sides so
this lattice size will be composed of
spins or electrons or or whatever
and in order to have a model this
lattice model you
must know and have to know what are the
interactions between the different
constituents and so for example so if
there is a spin
here and another spin here so what is
the interaction between those two spins
and by interaction what we mean is the
energy of interaction
so what we want to know is what is the
energy
and of different configurations so for
example you have a spin here up and spin
down
so then they will attract or repel
depending if these are magnets
and there is an energy associated to
that and so we would like to know what
is the energy of this configuration
and we would like to know all over the
lattice and in physics
this function this energy which is a
function of the configuration
so we typically write in terms of
something that we call a hamiltonian
so from now on you will hear very very
often this word hamiltonian like quantum
habitating complexity
so i will specify later on what i mean
but basically yes the energy so you give
me a configuration you give me
configurations of the spins
and then this is this gives you is a
function that gives you the energy for
this configuration
and that's all we need to know in order
to
answer the questions or almost
everything we need to know in order to
answer
the questions that i taught before so
you give in a system like that
and you put it on a lattice and you're
able to know what is this hamiltonian
this function
then in principle you should be able to
answer the questions about how this
this system will behave and so
why well because the properties like
transfer magnetic all the physical
properties that are here
are a function of this energy themselves
so for example
if you have thermal equilibrium so you
take your system and
your material and you wait for a while
then we know
that because of the interaction with the
environment it gets into some
state some configuration which is what
we call thermal equilibrium
and the thermal equilibrium according to
physics is a function
only of temperature a parameter and
this hamiltonian so this energy function
and you want to know what is dynamic so
what happens if you touch the system
change some spins so then they
they how they will evolve then we know
that the dynamics can be described
in terms again of this hamiltonian of
this function of the configuration
uh time because you want to know as a
function of time the parameter time
and the initial configuration so that's
why
it's so important for us this
hamiltonian so you will see it later on
i mean with examples and so on
but that's why it's a central part of a
model in physics
not only what is the lattice but also
what is the energy corresponding to the
different configurations
is what we call the hamiltonian i mean
for the moment it's not very besides
what i'm saying will become
more precise later on but if you have
this if you know the sanitary and then
in principle you can calculate
everything else and you can
calculate and and make the predictions
about what will happen with the systems
however this is the point of the talk is
that that's not enough
even though uh everything is encoded in
this hamiltonian
the answer to your questions actually it
may be very difficult
to predict the physical behavior even if
you know this hamiltonian this is
a difficult problem and that's why we
say that is a complex a complex problem
okay so actually now the following i'll
give you some examples to illustrate
that so for you
some of you computer scientists you will
understand it very well but i want to
distinguish
so uh between classical and quantum
systems so for the moment if you don't
know what quantum
system means just forget about that i'll
start with classical system which is
very simple to understand and then i'll
jump
to quantum systems and so i imagine that
i have
now a classical spin systems so we have
now
this uh classical spin so you want these
are bits
it can be spin up spin down you take the
value let's say plus one and minus one
and and so this is a configuration
that's our lattice for example in two
dimensions like it's
drawn here and imagine that somebody
gives us what is this energy of each
configuration so it gives us a way
of determining giving a configuration
what is the energy of this configuration
and i'm going to assume that we have
local interactions and so what it means
is that this
function of energy only depends on
pairwise configurations you said some
of all possible pairwise uh uh
configurations or a function of the
pairwise configuration
and uh but not not longer so in other
words they thought
you give me a configuration like this
one here like down up up
up then i can calculate the energy just
by looking at these two
these two and these two are these two at
all the pairs and that's
uh what happens in physics we know that
all the theories in physics from first
principles are local so things interact
only with the things that are close to
them
and so there are some other theories
which are effective theories which are
non-local
this will not be covered by microbes and
concentrate late
from now on on local theories in which
this energy is a sum
of energies that depend locally on what
are the computations
locally and i will consider also
the case of zero temperature so what
what it means in this context
is that i want to know what is the
configuration that minimizes
this energy this is the solution to the
problem okay so i'll give you
an an example classical so what
is the computation that minimizes the
energy so imagine that i give you
this configuration and i give you the
energy so how can you
solve the problem how can you find what
is the configuration
that minimizes the energy and after that
after you have this configuration then
in principle this should solve the
problems and you can calculate whether
it is a magnet or it's not a magnet or
it would be the behavior of the system
well what you have to do is to take
first the configuration with all spins
are down
this will be zero zero zero zero then
you plug it in this formula and then you
calculate some energy so let's put here
some energies
we have some units whatever it is then
you take zero zero zero zero zero zero
one
and then you compute the formula and
then you just incentive
and then you go all over all
possibilities
and then at the end you just look up
this table and say oh that's the lowest
energy
so this is the configuration but of
course this this method which is
trivial it's very bad because you have
to make a lot of calculations so there
are two to the n
configurations so if n is of the order
of 50 or 100 then it's impossible to
carry out
this problem so this is why this problem
unless
there is some structure is difficult of
course one can think that there are
ways of better calculating that or
finding that but actually there
before a general problem even if you
give configurations
uh that are local like i'm giving here
actually it's a hard problem we know
that it's np hard
and therefore it takes an exponential
time to solve the problem
as a function of the number of lattices
or the number of of
spins what happens in physics is that in
many cases
actually this this these functions that
appear here not so arbitrary it's just
not an
arbitrary function but there are some
symmetries so you take a piece of
material
many materials are almost homogeneous or
classic homogeneous you take this
floor and then over a scale i mean it
behaves the same in one position and
another position
and another position and so what it
means in practice is that in
many interesting cases the function that
appears here is homogeneous
namely the interaction between particle
one and two is the same that in particle
or two and three and three and four et
cetera et cetera
so this function is not so arbitrary and
you see that if you put this in the
problem then sometimes
then you can solve it right away so for
example instead yes the simplest case
in which we take another problem in
which now the energy of configuration is
given here
so the energy if the two spins are
pointing the same direction is minus one
and the energy of uh the configuration
in which they are pointing different
direction
is equal to plus one then you don't have
to look over all
configurations you can see right away
that the configuration with
all the spins are up where all the spins
are down
will minimize the energy no because it's
the lowest that you can have
in the energy you're always adding minus
one minus one minus one minus one
and then you can solve it so in this
case well we know that the solution
there are two solutions which minimize
the energy so you have a material
described by this model
and you cool it down to very low
temperature then all the spins will look
in the same direction it would be like
magnets all pointing the same direction
would be like a big magnet and this
would be a magnetic material so this is
what we call ferromagnetic material so
what we see is that sometimes when you
have
some symmetry in your problem and this
happens very often in physics
then you can solve the problem and
becomes very simple you can have another
model in which now
that's the other way around so the the
configuration
here is has a positive energy energy
positive if they are in the same point
in the same direction
and minus one if they are in different
direction
and you don't need to do the same
calculation i mean you can do it in many
ways one way
is just redefine the model flip every
second spin the b
lattice and then you're back to the
model that you had before then you know
the solution you flick it back and then
you see that the lowest energy is just
having alternating
spins so this is also a model that just
by looking at it basically directly then
you can solve it so again this is
called anti-ferromagnetic this is not a
magnet it's a different material it has
completely different properties than the
previous one
so in conclusion from the first
classical
part so if you take a classical problem
of spins
in a lattice and you want to know what
is the
zero temperature behavior of the system
that's very difficult in
in in general however in practice in
many
cases that for interest in physics so
especially when you have homogeneity
when you have translational invariance
then the system i mean the problem
simplifies and then you can solve it in
an
in an efficient way and on top of that
okay
there are many numerical methods to try
to approximate
this these models and that work at
finite temperature
so maybe it's very difficult sometimes
to calculate what is the
ground state or sorry the the lowest
energy configuration but maybe you don't
care so much about what is the lowest
energy configuration but you want to
know what are the low energy properties
of the configurations that have low
energies and you may still
uh uh i mean find it out numerically but
i don't want to to
enter that that field i will make some
comments at the end about that but at
the moment
just the conclusion so now let's change
to
quantum systems so actually the
materials
that are composing our world actually
don't don't obey the the loss of
classical mechanics so in some cases you
cannot treat them in the way that i
treat them before you cannot treat them
like
magnets that are spin up and spin down
and they have these two configurations
because they know that they are composed
of other particles they are composed of
atoms and the atoms of electrons and
nuclei and so on
and they obey the loss of quantum
mechanics so sometimes
it's required to use a quantum
description quantum piece
quantum mechanical description of these
systems and as we will see
this makes the problems even more
difficult than the classical ones
and so let's be a couple of words about
quantum quantum physics so as you know
it was developed
during uh the 100 years ago
starting from the hypothesis of planck
who basically said uh something which
was a kind of a scandal at that time
so uh as you probably know and
from this 19th century and 17th century
so people were convincing themselves
that light had to be
a wave could not be made out of
particles and
and there were some people before to say
that light should be particles so when i
see something is that there's something
is bouncing on my eye
but then there's also phenomena that
could not be described in terms of
particles and these were diffraction and
interference
and difference phenomena and but on the
other hand there were some other
experiments that they were doing at the
end of the
19th century in which they could only be
understood if actually the light
was made out of particles what now we
call photons and plants was the person
who pointed that out and after that
there was the revolution which came out
to the fact that nowadays so we can
understand from
elementary particles all the way to
nuclear atoms molecules and even
material
and we believe that all of them are
described with
with quantum quantum mechanics and i
mean just just to mention
a number so we we can make measurements
today of predictions made of
out of quantum mechanics with 13 and 14
digits so it's the best ever
let's say verified or test tested
theory that we have ever had so so
actually a very accurate and so we
believe that it's
when we have a material so you could uh
uh
solve that quantum mechanical problem
then you could describe everything that
will will happen there okay so it's a
theory that we believe very well at
least for this for this
system that are here and we also
understand very well that under some
conditions when you have
quantum mechanics and some conditions
occur then you can replace quantum
mechanics by classical mechanics
so going to the case of materials so
sometimes we know that the materials we
don't have to have a quantum description
but
the spins up and this magnet is enough
but sometimes that's not enough and
that's the ones that i want to
to describe here okay so for the ones
who have not
heard about quantum mechanics or only
superficially let me uh remind you of of
one of the main issues of quantum
mechanics which was which is very
parsley
and that's adored when she gave her talk
i mean she had the same transparency i
think that we
physicists and computer scientists when
we want to describe quantum mechanics we
show it very often it's a double-slit
experiment it's
it's a very simple experiment that was
done already more than 100 years ago
in which they put a source of light
and then they make two holes two slits
and in the wall and they let the pass go
through
and they put the screen after that and
they see where the light comes
and you do this experiment and these
lights have to be a bit special cannot
be the light that is coming from
from from the bulb has to be from a lace
has to be monochromatic
then what you will see is that the light
appears in some
particular ways and does not appear in
some other ways and that's nothing else
but the interference phenomena which
led people to think that light was made
made out of waves
and because otherwise it's very
difficult to understand
this this phenomenon in fact i mean the
the way that you describe in terms of
of waves is you say okay so there is
some light and the weight is coming here
and then when the light crosses the
holes then there is some wave crossing
from here
no some way that it starts here is a way
that starts here like the
sea waves and these two waves now the
propagates like in the sea
and then if you look at some position
then it may happen at
this position the crest of the
wave comes together coming from here
comes at the same time that the crest of
the wave coming from the other side so
this way you have maximum energy maximum
light coming there
and in some of the positions then is the
the valley
of the wave with the value of the wave
is coming and then where is there is no
light and that's fine i mean this is the
firmament of interference basically
so but as i mentioned before so planck
in in 1900 so
he said that in order to understand some
other phenomena i mean the description
was not good enough so you should
describe it in terms of particles
so then how can one understand that if
you have a source of light which is
emitting photos it's like small balls
and then across the two holes that you
can have some places where there is
light coming and places where there is
no light coming and that's really a
puzzle it's really a possible because
i mean if they were balls if you do this
experiment with tennis balls and you
will see that some of them appear
in this region and some of them appear
within regions so the ones that go
to the first hole will appear in this
region and the other ones in this region
so you will not see
some fringes you will see just two
regions however
actually you can do the experiment with
light
and you do the experiment and then you
see that in fact this is what happens
so people may think that okay this is
what happens we
we may have still these particles but
what happens that they
push each other and because uh they push
each other then this is why they decide
to go to some regions and
and to disappear from some of the
reaches well actually this is not true
because the experiments are done
now for many years sending just a single
photon per second so there is
at the time only one photon inside this
region
and you still see that the first photon
appears here maybe the second here
randomly appears
but when you have recorded many things
that you see that they appear in fringes
so they decide
one by one to appear in some places and
it not in some other places
and so you think about that and you cut
this description of the ball the only
way
of understanding this kind of experiment
is that
each of the photons had to go through
both slits at the same time and that's
of course very counterintuitive no
because
when you don't see that the tennis ball
go through
two slits at the same time but actually
that's the only way around to
to saying that you have uh particles
and interference and that's something
that is very weird about quantum
mechanics somehow that the life of
these particles can't uh kind of uh
double and then in one life is doing
something and another light
is doing something else and when we
think that that's a property of photons
but that's not true this experiment has
been done with electrons so one is able
to take two electrons from here one
electron after one electron make to slit
put in this seize the fringes again so
the electrons also go through the two
holes at the same time
but when we think that the electrons are
too elementary and they're weird
particles
what people have done is experiment with
atoms with all atoms composed of nuclei
and electrons
and with molecules and with big
molecules so with fullerenes and etc etc
so that's something
that we understand very well and is
described by quantum mechanics
and you want to describe with your hands
then you have to say that
the particle each of the particles went
through the two is lit at the same time
because this doesn't make sense someone
has to learn quantum mechanics to
understand what
i mean by what i'm saying but that's one
of the features of quantum mechanics
which of course has very surprising uh
properties and we have
maybe teleportation and some other words
that are i mean this is responsible for
the existence of these possibilities
but actually this is also responsible
for the fact
that quantum problems or describing
quantum mechanically materials
it's very hard as i will show you in a
second okay so
taking now uh what we learned from these
double slit experiments
it tells us that uh so when we have a
particle like this a spin that i
mentioned before
so we described before as a as a bit
basically spin up or spin down zero one
values but in quantum mechanics this is
not enough so we can have not only spin
up
but this pin down but we can also have
the two possibilities at the same time
so this is what we call
superposition and that's something that
comes in quantum mechanics it doesn't
make any classical sense
so and that's something that we write in
this form so at the moment you don't
have to understand this formula this
once it only tells you that you have at
the same time
zero and one in the same way that this
particle could be at the same time
in the left and the right uh slit when
they went through
and what is important is to know that in
quantum mechanics you have to
each of these possibilities of these
configurations now that they can occur
at the same time
are weighted by some complex factors
this is what we call the coefficients of
the superposition
and these coefficients will tell us
whether we are very classical or we are
not very classical for example in the
first coefficient is this coefficient is
zero
then we have we have just state what we
call state zero
which means that we have like like a
spin down a very classical spin down
and if this coefficient is zero then it
means that we have the spin up so it's a
very
mean just classical state of the spin
but actually these coefficients may be
different from zero
and then what they tell us is if we
would measure this spin
what would be the probability of
obtaining certain outcomes so if i
take a spin and this quantum spin is
described
by let's say this formula here then if i
want to calculate if i
measure now if it's spin up or spin down
this c zero
actually the absolute value square will
tell us the probability of obtaining
and having it in zero and one the
priming it in five
this is not so important for the moment
the point that i want to make
is that in classically a bit can take
two configurations
zero and one and if i tell you that my
bit is zero and one you don't have to
know anything else
however in quantum mechanics there are
more possibilities if i want to tell you
what is my system what is the state of
my system so what is my system doing
i will have to tell you how much is c0
and c1 so i will have to tell you
not only if it's zero or up but i will
have to tell you what are these complex
coefficients
now you can have many of these pins for
example two
and something similar happens so you
have now two classical bits
then they can be in four possible
configurations zero zero zero one one
zero one one
however if you have now quantum spins
then they can be in these four possible
configurations but
also in any superposition they're all so
it could be at the same time in zero
zero zero one
one zero one one and now you you want to
specify
so what is the quantum state of the
system so you want to predict anything
about this system then you have to tell
me
what is the coefficient in front of each
other configuration so you will have to
give me
four coefficients actually one example
of that it's a very famous example that
appears many
times in physics is this zero one minus
one zero you have this place this is
what we call singlet
and let me give you an example where the
singlet appears
so now let's go back to uh the spin
lattices
and imagine that they have a lattice
which is called cargo melates which has
these structures like
it starts putting next together and you
can have for example
a system of spins quantum spins in which
this pair is in a singlet this pair
isn't a singlet this pair isn't a single
displacement singular disparation is
english
and this is what we call a valence one
state so it's it's like the
pairs are paired you know with each
other in some particular configuration
and if you write down these states so
you will have to take the state instead
if they multiply them out so you will
have a
superposition of many many many many
many configurations at the same time
actually you can have another fancier
state
if you realize so here what we are doing
is that we're tearing the
vertices of these lattices the nearest
neighbor lattices and there are many
ways of bearing them so for example
instead of putting this singlet here
singularity here singularity you could
have
the singlet here another singlet here
another signal here in such a way that
they don't overlap
and this would be another varnish one
state but now you can have according to
quantum mechanics also
the linear superposition of all these
possible configurations a very
complicated state this is what is called
a resonating balance bond state in this
journal just wanted to give you an
example of some states that can appear
and actually this has some relevance
because it's related
to some very fancy properties of
materials anyway
let me let me go back to the to the case
of spins
and now with quantum mechanics now
imagine that now we have the same
lattice as before where we have these
small magnets but these magnets now are
described quantum mechanical so they are
not either spin down or spin up so they
can have these superpositions
so it means that if i want to know what
is the state at zero temperature
and i want to tell you what is the state
at zero temperature such that you can
make any prediction you want to know
whether it's conducting or conducting
other properties
then i will have to give you all the
possible coefficients for all possible
configurations
so just writing down the state that that
that is say the relevant state involves
2 to the n complex coefficient that i
have to give you
and if you want to compute anything so
once you have the state
maybe you want to know some
configuration maybe you want to know
what is the energy
the configuration because at the end you
want to know what is the one that
minimizes the energy the
the the the configuration that minimizes
the energy the lowest temperature
then then you will have to calculate
some uh expectation values with those
with all these coefficients you will
have to do an x also a huge number of
computations
and this is where the problem in quantum
the additional problem
in quantum physics comes from that
not not finding the configuration is is
difficult it's
just writing down if if i tell you if i
know what is the configuration i want to
write it down
then i have to give you a vector with
two to the n coefficients so if
n is of the order of 50 then i mean we
cannot put it in any computer and if
it's 300
300 spins then if we could store one bit
of information in all the particles of
the universe all the atoms of the
universe would not be enough to
and that's the problem this explosion of
coefficients in quantum mechanics
even to specify the stage you're not
even to calculate properties
so that's a problem a new problem that
ends in attention when we're describing
this
many body systems quantum many body
systems and the second
one is that once you imagine that i give
you this this coefficient so that i
tell you what is my configuration then
you would like to
calculate something that you have to
make predictions and according to the
rules of quantum mechanics
the predictions are just calculating
expectation values you take this vector
put some operator here which will be the
physical property that you want to
describe
and then you have to multiply it again
with a vector so this will require
an exponential number of simple
calculations so the time that it will
require to do this
computation will also grow exponentially
with the with the size of your system
and so that's i mean an additional
problem in quantum physics that
that it's not in classical physics and
one could say so what happens with
symmetry you remember classically i
thought well
we know that we have certain symmetries
we know that all the uh
that you have a homogeneous system then
this helps a lot well actually in these
problems
this doesn't help a lot because there
are many many many many configurations
which are homogeneous
and classically you have two only oh
spins up and spin downs these are the
ones that are homogeneous
quantum mechanically there are many
actually there are two to the n divided
by n so you can see for example this is
one
this is a superposition which i have
zero zero zero zero zero one plus zero
zero zero zero one zero plus zero plus
one zero zero
so this if you see actually is even
permutation or invariant is homogeneous
and permutation invariant and it's a
valid configuration it's neither all
zeros nor
one and there are many of them
exponentially many so giving
telling you that you have translational
invariance may not help so much
to solve to solve the problem as if they
in the class in the classical case okay
so
now we can compare classical and quantum
problems so classical problems the
description
it's obviously easy it's a configuration
we're requiring bits of information to
tell you what is the solution
the physical properties one and once i
know the configuration it's very simple
you just have to call it some kit end
times and you have to do some operation
and find the configuration may be
difficult right this uh
probabilities and be hard as we said
before but in some cases it becomes
easy but quantum the quantum system in
full generality everything
is difficult even describing the system
is difficult and
that's a challenge if you want to
describe properties of material like the
one that i mentioned before because it
has quantum profits it cannot be
described classically
or you want to solve the standard model
or you want to study chemical reactions
etc etc
okay but however i mean that's not the
end of it so i mean at the end people
chemists are able to to to predict
things with their chemical systems and
there are
many materials that we know how to
behave so
what happens is that uh there are some
conditions under which these problems
become easy
and so so that's actually what we were
studying in this in this in this program
so we wanted to know
under which conditions so if maybe it's
if it's homogeneous it's not enough but
all
conditions which are very physically
relevant maybe the problems become easy
and then you can solve it and we wanted
to assess
so where do the do a classification of
of quantum problems
so let me give you give you some some
possibilities so for example
uh then i did some so i was i was
working with a description in which i'm
working with these long vectors but
maybe there is another description that
does not require to write vector in this
huge space
maybe there is a more efficient
description of the of this of this
configuration
which is not exponential in space and so
this would
mean that maybe we can do computation
much better on the other hand
so actually we don't want to have we
don't need to have the whole thing we
don't need all these two to the end
coefficients at the end we want to
calculate we want to compute
some microscopic properties as i
mentioned before we want to know whether
this
system is superconducting is a magnet
it's not a magnet how it will react from
very simple questions we don't need to
do the n coefficients so maybe
i mean in order to solve the question
we're overdoing it just by trying to
get all the information about this this
uh this
quantum superposition so in fact as i
mentioned before actually there are many
methods to describe many body quantum
systems we work with condensed matter to
high energy physics and so they have
their methods and they are able to solve
problems because they are relying on
some of these some of these properties
but even with the methods that we have
in hand i mean there are still some
problems that cannot be addressed
actually many products that cannot be
addressed with current methods and
that's i mean that's the example that i
told you before
it's an open problem many open problems
also in
high energy and many other problems in
in chemistry et cetera et cetera
so this is why i mean this is the
motivation of this project to
try to assess this now from the computer
science point of view what is difficult
or not and if it's difficult
maybe try to to find algorithms for
which this is simply
okay so this is these are some results
during the last years and i'm very sorry
about the
the reference here so my reference here
i mean or not are not
very appropriate but anyway i didn't
have time to look it up and i didn't
remember
so that's a summary of some of the
results actually that have occurred
during the last year have been revised
in this workshop and
in particular last week's potential
network meeting
and actually so now you can have
physical systems which have some extra
conditions that are very relevant from
the physical point of view then these
problems become easy in one example
is when you have a one-dimensional
system so you have like one cable not a
three-dimensional
just one cable and the system is got and
i'll explain it in a second what i mean
by by gapped
in that case actually by people here
show that that the description is easy
that
not using heal space and all that but
there's another method
we showed that the computer the physical
properties is simple
and to find what is the the smallest
energy configuration is ecc and i'll i
want to explain it a little bit
and in higher dimensions then it happens
that you you add an extra condition on
top of that so it's not only that these
the interactions are local that i
mentioned but they are also gap but also
that the density of states grows
polynomially with a number of sites
which i will explain in a second
then it turns out that the description
is easy but still we don't know how to
how to find efficiently the the physical
properties or to find
the configuration so it's getting a
little bit more like classical like
classical problems and i want to explain
a little bit
this diagram so what do we
mean and now it's getting a little bit
more more technical
the talk so what what do i mean by this
gap
systems so at the end remember that i
told you that if you have a
one of these spin systems then
everything is described in terms of this
hamiltonian this is the energy
not for each configuration and at the
end this hamiltonian is like a big
matrix which is composed
now by some elements so this is a sum of
the
energy of this configuration quantum
configuration the energy of this
configuration so we write this
hamiltonian as a sum
of terms like the base of the classical
case and now this is a big
big matrix and it turns out that the
minimal configuration
is nothing else mathematically to find
the minimum combination reduces
to finding what is the eigenvector
corresponding to the minimum eigenvalue
of this big matrix so this is what we
say
colloquially we say we have to find what
is the ground state of that hamiltonian
so the ground state of that hamiltonian
so the eigenvector corresponding to the
minimum eigenvalue is the solution will
be the state the solution
so we'll be the state of that system at
zero temperature
and so now you can understand that if we
want to make
statements of how difficult is to find
the ground state to find the eigen
eigenvector course of this of this big
matrix
then this will have something to do with
the spectrum of this of this
hamiltonian of these matrix and in fact
now you can have different kind of
spectrums
so depending of how your interactions
are
then you look at the spectrum so it
could be something like that there would
be
like the minimum energy this is the next
energy the next energy the next energy
so this is a finite matrix so it will
have a discrete spectrum
so there are some values and this is for
some lattice
let's say for n0 particles in your
lattice size and this is
this is the state that you're interested
in the one that minimizes the energy
that's the one that you want to find
now what can happen is that you increase
the lattice side you make it bigger
and now there will be more because your
matrix is larger so it has more
eigenvalues
so it will mean more values in the
spectrum and
now you increase more then there will be
more and more and more and actually the
maximum will go up as well and there are
some conditions that have to infiltrate
but that's the typical thing what
happens
so we say that that the hamiltonian or
the system is gapped
when the distance the energy distance
between the
the this ground state and the next
uh eigenvalue it's bounded from below
so it remains constant
larger than zero for any value of n so
you would increase your system make it
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
still there is a gap
here this is why it's called gap and it
turns out that generically
this is true in in the hamiltonians that
appear in in nature so you take a
hamiltonian
that appears in nature which is
homogeneous and you just write random
numbers you put it there then
i mean this is something that typically
occurs so this is why these are relevant
cases the case of gap hamiltonian and
so the cap hamiltonian actually
physically
basically means that the state will be
robust so you're
at zero temperature and you modify
something the physical properties of
your state
will not change and that's what happens
in bracket detectives and then we change
it a little bit and this doesn't explode
that's one of the properties that occurs
and
it's also related to something which is
called finite correlation length so
whenever you have
a gap in your system then automatically
you know that's the correlations in your
system
will decay exponentially there will be a
typical length so you do you measure
something here and something here and
you get a longer longer distance then
they don't have to do anything with each
other are
completely decorated okay so again so if
you take now
one-dimensional systems well maybe maybe
explain first for the object so this is
what is what is the
what we mean by cap now what about the
other condition for height dimension
this is the density of state
let's take the spectrum again of our
hamiltonian
and increase the number of particles and
let's consider some
values some energy and let's make a line
like that
okay and we consider that this
entertains how we renormalize the energy
saturated
the energy is always the same here so
now what we can do that we can count how
many states are here
so how many states have energy smaller
than this e
and see how this number increases as we
have bigger and bigger lattices so this
is what is called the density of states
or a system of n sites corresponding to
some energy a
e is the number of states that are here
and this number typically will grow
because they are more uh the matrix is
bigger than there are more
numbers in the spectrum the more more
more
eigenvalues in this region however now
this can increase in different ways and
one possible way is that it increases
polynomially so it increases kind of
slowly that you're putting making it
bigger and bigger and bigger
then there are not too many states most
of the states are
appearing in the center so that's the
condition that the density of states
has some particular
property and a way of thinking about
that so whether this corresponds
physically
so what it means basically is that your
system can be thought of systems of
different patches so that
since you said you have gaps you have a
finite correlation length
things that are far away are the
correlated then you have like a patch
here which has nothing to do with
something that is far away then here
they have another patch
you can think of your system as made out
of patches and think and study
things locally and if you have
assistance with patches they would be
really systematic patches and they
fulfill this condition it's very simple
to see that that
then they fulfill this condition and
that's why it's related to that
okay and this is also a very generic
property i mean that's harder to say i
mean harder to i mean
we know that there are counter examples
to that but in most of the physical
hamiltonians that appear in nature and
this is a property that also
occurs so now going back to the this to
the table that i had before
so it seems that for one-dimensional
relevant systems in physics
then we have that all these problems are
easy
and for the relevant uh problems in in
physical
many of the relevant problems we see the
description is easy
still calculating things with them or
finding the configuration within the
ground state is difficult
and i want to i want to explain it so i
want to explain why this description is
easy
because what do we do do we don't work
in hilbert space we don't write these
these vectors anymore we use a different
language to do that and also to do that
and that's what is called a tensor
network
description and that was actually the
the the subject of the workshop that
took place in this
in this uh science institute last week
okay so coming back to the original
problem
i have a lattice model describing some
physical system
this lattice model is quantum so we have
quantum
spins systems and so we have a
hamiltonian so we know
what are the interactions between the
systems and the questions is we would
like to know
what is the ground state what is the
minimal energy configuration
and from the ground state so we want to
proper to calculate properties like
energies or magnetic magnetization etc
etc now
as i mentioned before this ground state
at the end will be a vector which has
this two to the n components
but actually this is over this is uh a
killer so we don't need
this too many components and it's very
simple to see that just counting
parameters
so this vector lives in a space which
has this dimension 2 to the power n this
is the dimension of the hilbert space
where this with this vector leaves
but actually it cannot be that we can
somehow that we need the whole vector
that all vectors are possible
and this is because we're asking a very
peculiar question we are asking what is
the ground state
of a matrix which has a very special
form so
it's local so it's only it's a sum of
interactions of particles which are next
to each other this is a very specific
question
so what means in practice is that
actually from the whole human space
actually there will be only one corner
of this hero space
where our vectors will be living they
are very special they are ground states
of some or they are
eigenvectors of some peculiar matrices
so they have to be very special
and this is the thing that gives the
that tells us that maybe there is a way
of describing not
just by writing this vector by using a
different description and so
let me do this counting of parameters
because it's very simple so
so why i'm saying that well you see so
this
this uh hamiltonian that is here depends
basically
on uh the interaction that i have here
so
it's a sum of interactions so it will
depend on the interactions between these
two particles these two particles these
two particles these two particles these
two particles so how many
pairs of particles we have well if
everybody interacts with everybody they
are n squared but here they're even less
because
they're everybody's interacting only
with the neighbor so it would be
something like the number of particles
times the coordination numbers or force
in two dimensions something like that so
for four times n
terms in this sum and each of the term
that appears here
tells me what is the interaction between
these two these two spins only two spins
does not depend on it anymore this is a
constant number so actually it will be
something like 16 parameters
so the total all the possible
hamiltonians
know that we are considering here depend
only on
16 times n for
something that grows linearly with n
with the number of with the number of
particles
but the ground state is a function of
this angular if i give you the
hamiltonian
is like specifying the ground state so
the ground state may only depend on it
can only depend on these
let's say n parameters of 20 n
parameters not exponentially and this is
what we say
is a qualitative way of saying that only
some quarter of illustrates a zero
measure let's say
manifold of states that we live there or
vectors that we live there
are relevant for our ground state so
when we are trying to write all these
vectors with all these
confusion with all these coefficients we
are overdoing it
because we are treating all possible
states here on equal footing
and actually this is not what we want
we're solving some very specific
problems
and in fact that's what gives us the
hint that there might be a better
description and this gives
the hint why this can be work better
okay
so maybe maybe there is a description of
this corner which is the relevant corner
of gilbert space that we call
that that that has very few parameters
so the number of parameters only grows
let's say polynomially with the number
of particles
and for which maybe we can calculate
physical properties efficiently and find
what is the configuration
efficiently but how how do we find this
corner of hillbilly space
and so i'll tell you what is the hint
that that guided people to find this
corner of human space and that's what
it's called
area law and so let me explain also
qualitatively what this aerial law is
so it turns out that the ground states
the zero energy configurations of these
particular hamiltonians which are local
uh which have local interactions have uh
well it's conjecture and in some cases
it's proven that will feel some
kind of universal law and this law is
represented here so this is the lattice
again
and imagine that now from the lattice i
take one
subsystem so this is what i call
subsystem a
in the sub system a we can calculate
what is the entropy the entropy is a
is a informational information
information theoretical variables which
is also a thermodynamic value basically
with the same meaning
you have to extend it to quantum
mechanics that can be extended
and you can you can calculate what is
the entropy of this
region if you are in the ground state of
the system and
it turns out that if you take any vector
of heat respect a random vector on this
space
then it will scale so this entropy will
be a number
for this ritual which will be
proportional to the number of particles
you have in this region
however in the case that we are in the
corner of hebrew space of relevant human
space it turns out that this is not so
so that the entropy of this region
depends on the particles the number of
is proportional to the particles that
are and the boundary of this region this
is what is called the area it depends on
the area not on the volume
of the system and that's very peculiar
and actually as i mentioned before it
can for example for gap system is in one
dimension it can be proven for gap
systems in two dimensions with density
of states fulfilling what i told you can
be proven
is something that is very generic in
these cases but this tells us
so this tell us that that actually there
is a way that we can look for this
description of killer space so what is
what is the idea the idea is to find all
the description
in such a way that all states fulfilling
the area law
have uh uh are within this description
okay so you look at the way of
formulating or
writing states to say configurations
nothing to respect but in a different
way
exactly that the number of parameters is
small scales polynomially with the
number of particles
but we are sure that if a state fulfills
the area law
it can be written with this description
with this polynomial number of
parameters and therefore since the state
the diagram state fulfill the area loss
and we will be able to write them with
this description
efficiently that's a little bit the idea
behind that
and so uh so maybe let me tell you what
is a
what is a an intuitive idea behind this
area that can be proven in some cases
so and so the the entropy
now gets a bit more complicated but the
entropy
in quantum information in quantum
physics measures
so how much you have and how much
uh you are entangled or region a is
entangled to region b
okay so you have a product state so you
have
something which doesn't have this kind
of superpositions
that uh that i mentioned before then it
turns out the difficulty where the
entropy is zero
and the more you are in superposition
more you have entanglement then
you uh then this entropy grows it's a
measure of entanglement in fact this
entropy in quantum information
so but now i mentioned that we have a
cap system like the ones that i
mentioned before
then we know that there is a correlation
length so it means that
only the particles that are around this
region here
will be correlated will be kind of
entangled and so
if you calculate now what is the entropy
what is the entanglement between the
interior and exterior it will depend
only on the particles that are in this
region so it would be equal to the
numbers that are in the boundary times
this correlation length
and this is why you have this area for
gap systems and that's why
these systems are very peculiar
okay so actually now in case of the
aerial so it has been actually for one
dimensional system that targa has been
proven
that there is of yellow even for critics
for critical systems some systems
that are gapless but somehow are
relevant in physics for some other
reasons are scaling variant et cetera et
cetera
they fulfill an aerial value with a
violation which goes like the logarithm
of the size of your system and in higher
dimensions also you take
gap systems with these conditions from
the density of state you also violate
the aerials it's
quite a generic generic word okay so if
you have this rule then
you can think of a of a of a description
and i'll i'll finish with that and now
it gets a little bit more technical so
it's just
the end of the talk in terms of tensor
network so what is a tensor network and
why
this describes efficiently the systems
and once
you have this efficient description then
you can use this description in order to
find
these configurations and to compute
things and this is the way in which they
prove
all these properties that i mentioned
before okay so
i come again about my to my slatted
system with the hamiltonian my state
i told you that my state can be written
as a vector
a vector which has many components like
like c
zero zero zero zero zero zero c one two
to the n component
so let me write this vector as a tensor
it's a tensor which has
an uh n indices so the first thing the
second industry
et cetera et cetera i will write it like
that so this means that this is a tensor
in which these are the indices of my
tensor and
my hamiltonian my hamiltonian is an
operator is a matrix
so it has now indices to the left and to
the right
okay so it says the same language it's
another tensor but it has
double the indices so some of the
indices are to the left and some of the
indices on the right
and when we calculate the energy or when
we calculate some expectation value when
we predict certain
property in physics what we do is that
we calculate something like that i told
you if we take the vector
the vector the math is a vector so in
this language what we do is that we take
the vector
we take the the matrix the vector and
then multiply multiplies by contracting
indices
so at the end quantum mechanics is
nothing else but working with tensors
which have many indices and the fact
that they have many indices means that
these
they are very difficult because then
there are many coefficients that's the
problem
in terms of tensors but now there are
some special kind of tensors
and uh this is what we call tensor
networks so imagine that
the tensor that i have can be written in
terms of smaller tensors
these are these smaller tensors that are
here that are contracted in some
particular form
so for example this is a tensor which is
rank 3 tensor
and now what we take is that this tensor
here so for example
if we put in distance of the coefficient
zero zero zero zero zero would be the
same
as putting in this tense or a zero here
another zero here not receiving these
small tensors and contracting all them
together so multiplying like matrices
contracting indices
then you see that i can if this is equal
to that
then i can describe this two to the n
coefficients actually with much less
effort
why because the number of of of
coefficients that i need to use
are the number of questions to describe
these small tensors and the number of
coefficients to describe
this small tensor is the number of
tensors times the number of coefficients
for one tensor
and if this doesn't scale with them then
i will have that the number
of tensors that i need to describe the
whole tensor
actually this case only linearly with
the with the number of particles
okay so by chance it turns out that
the states which are the ground state
the solution to our problems
can be written in terms of contraction
of smaller tensors
then we may be able to describe them
efficiently because instead of
calculating this big tension we work
with small tensors
and then we'll be able to solve the
problem so
i have no time to to well maybe maybe
to explain here so this is an example so
this is what is called the matrix
product stage it tensor for
one-dimensional systems
in which this tensor the transfer is
coefficient
you write it in terms of these smaller
tensors and contract it only
horizontally
and uh just the same version if you call
the project
in two dimensions in which now the
tensor
the indices of the tensor are pointing
out and you get
this tensor now just by contracting the
tensors along the other the other
possible indices
okay well it turns out that it's uh
don't have time to
to tell you but one can show that if you
if you
state fulfills the area law okay then
you have an efficient description in
terms of this tensor so in fact your
tensor your big tensor can be decomposed
in terms of smaller tensor so then you
can have a handle
to describe it and when it's a
conjecture
it's conjecture and it's very likely
that it's true that in two dimensions
this is also
this is also true so that whenever we
have an aerial law then these
different difficult tests can be written
in terms of smaller tensors and then we
have a deficient description and this is
why
one can prove that under certain
circumstances we have efficient
descriptions because this can be made
rigorous and then
you have efficient descriptions and in
the case of one-dimensional system then
it turns out
that you can compute uh expectation
values efficiently
because calculating this expectation
value now with this tensor and one can
see when we
just listen to what i say is a matrix
multiplication you have to take a small
vector which is just the small tensors
and do matrix multiplication and this
can be done very efficiently and this is
why
so you have a problem which is gap which
is the arrow you have a tensor
description
this tensor description you can compute
things efficiently and you can find it
officially because of this property
because at the end you can do matrix
multiplication
in which the size of the matrix does not
depend on the size of the of the system
or depend
on depending on your polynomial in the
size of the system that's why it's
efficient
however in two dimensions you have a
two-dimensional problem or a
three-dimensional problem then it turns
out that you can
in fact there exists a description in
terms of these these tensors
under certain circumstances however the
problem is that you cannot compute
expectation values easily so i had a
small explanation but let me tell you
that is related
to the fact that at the end computing
expectation value is contracting a big
tensor
but now this tensor is very connected so
whenever you want to
compute and calculate these properties
then it turns out
that your tensor when you're contracting
will become very big will have many
coefficients and then
this will expose and this makes a
difference between one dimensional and
two-dimensional
okay so i want to just finish saying
that
because this is mentioned things that
are normal that have been discussed in
this workshop that there are
many things that are not known and
people are working on that so for
example
so people are trying to describe
critical systems so systems that are not
gapped
with other tensor descriptions not the
ones that i mentioned here some that are
called tree tensor networks meta et
cetera et cetera
another thing is that maybe since we're
interested only calculating
some physical properties then we don't
need to approximate the whole ground
state so maybe this
tensor description is even too much to
describe the whole thing because we are
interested in very few things
there are all the people trying to look
at more efficient descriptions even at
this
tensor description another thing that's
fungal interesting is that in two
dimensions i told you
that it's very difficult to contract
these tensors and this is why we cannot
compute things in two dimensions but if
you have symmetries
it may happen that you can contract some
of these tensor in some cases
efficiently
and this will open up the possibility of
describing not only one-dimensional
systems but only
also higher dimensional systems
efficiently i didn't talk about
zero final temperature so it turns out
that and i mean the same thing that i
was explaining here works at finer
temperature in some cases even better
dynamics etc etc well with that i just
uh wanted to give you an overview also
what we have been discussing
and but emphasizes more than the
technical details so what were the
motivations
behind what are the results that are
known and so what are some of the open
problems
in the field so thank you for your
attention
uh maybe you said it but i missed it a
lot a lot of the second half of your
talk
was based on systems with a gap
what's the motivation why should we care
about systems with a gap
because gap basically means robustness
okay so that you have to put a lot of
energy to change the system this is what
it means i got
but if you have a system that is not
robust then you will not find it in
nature
okay because any perturbation will
change it so this is why many of the
systems that we have
in nature are gapped and these are the
interesting behavior
of course there are people who are
interested in very exotic behaviors or
one happens when the states are very
sensitive to certain conditions and then
this would be gapless systems so give us
an example of a gap
system if you care about gap system any
insulator
for example anything that is compressed
is not compressible
well when you have for example uh i mean
fermions moving
uh freely okay so particles moving just
in a
in a conductor without any resistance or
anything i mean this is a
double system but if you put any any
impurity then it will not move and that
will become the gun
so just to see the historical comment
you mentioned the interference is about
100 years old
you must be a very young man no no it's
about 200 years okay
eighteen or four if i remember right
okay well yeah
i'm sure that there are many many
precisions in my talk but
that's the only one that i can it's good
that the mathematician corrects a
physicist on interference
can you say anything more about the
dynamics
okay the dynamics is the difficult part
so i mean
i personally believe and some of us
personally believe
that at the end most of the systems that
are interesting from the physical point
of view that are in thermally grieving
at zero temperature or finite
temperature but that have accumulated
can be described efficiently i mean in
some sense or another
but we believe that quantum systems that
have dynamics
probably not and so systems in which you
just make a perturbation and see what is
the propagation of this perturbation
and one of the main reasons for that is
because uh
uh uh there's something which is called
a quantum computer you may have heard or
that is a dynamic resistance in which
things are changing and that we believe
that is much more powerful than any
classical computer and that we cannot
simulate efficiently so in fact
we would be able to simulate dynamics
with these tensors or some other methods
efficiently then we will not need a
quantum computer because we could do the
computations
classically and what happens with these
tensors actually
is that when you have that i mean in the
context of what i was explaining here
the way that you understand
that with this tension you cannot
describe dynamics is that whenever you
have dynamics the area law
is violated so at the time that is
constant
let's say the area look exposed and this
is why
this tensor description is no longer
valid
so in terms of
this hypothesis that uh i guess the
physical systems have a tensor
description
um are there any experimental
results that sort of
i don't know or that you could design an
experimental result that would sort of
um
test this well the the
i mean what i say that i mean now going
a little bit more detail
is based on on the fact that the finite
at any finite temperature you have an
efficiency
an efficient description if you have
local hamilton i mean local interactions
as we were discussing and at that zero
temperature i mean we get this end to
the power log n
which i mean probably you can get rid of
this log n at some point i mean it's not
based on the area law but it's based on
a different on a different
reason why i mentioned that but i didn't
want to enter into into this
exponential matrices
it's i mean there might be exceptions
but if
i mean you take a textbook where they
put examples of typical
hamiltonians that appear and you can
solve you will find that this is the
case
and then i give you i gave you what is
the
the kind of i mean back of the envelope
calculation so indeed if your system is
finite correlation length
you may think of having different
patches actually we have to make it
translational invariant but this will
give a good approximation obviously this
linear superposition
of products or patches translated
and then you have patches then this is
fulfilled and you have a linear
superposition this keeps also
that's the intuitive motivation behind
it
so about the local interactions so it's
pretty clear what
pairwise interactions means in 1d but in
higher d
is there like a problem in terms of
whether you include the diagonal
interactions
no that's i mean all the statements are
included in black
interactions as long as there is a
finite range and some of the results can
be even
can be extended to the fact that to the
to this time that you have exponentially
decaying interactions at any length and
many other interactions
and even some polynomial power decay if
it's sufficiently hard
ask a question so so you mentioned
you know that that uh from a natural
system there should be an area law
including from critical systems with the
logarithmic connection
so is there a can you think of a
you know is there a way to formulate
that statement like in the gap
case in a in a form that might be being
precise
actually can be precise even in the case
that i mentioned
and but then this is the definition of
what critical is yeah
so critical well you can have two
definitions one
is with kind of a statistical invariant
okay so that you calculate the
correlation function at some distance
you multiply the distance by two
you don't have the same correlation
function but maybe divide by with one
divided by 2 to the
power delta and if this happens for all
possible correlation functions we say
that this
this is that this is uh
scaling variant and so critical is
equivalent to the scaling variant
and maybe there are ways of formulating
so there is a way of formulating which
is a bit more restrictive we say that
this
describe in terms of a conformal field
theory and the conformation theories of
field theory
which by definition is scaling variant
and for those it has been proven
in one dimension so for comfort for
theories for conformal field theories
which are all critical
this is this has been proven but the
meaning is to that this is the image so
that the
all possible correlation function
detains some specific ways
and so so could you could you imagine a
simpler way of excluding the qna hard
hardness results for 1d yes because it's
uh
it's something that this is this is this
is scaling variant
i think it's not critical so there is a
belief
that when you have a gap and you change
your parameters and you have a
transition you close the gap and this is
the second order interesting
phase transition then you get uh you get
an extra symmetry which is scaling
variance
and then this is why people have studied
these critical theories and they're so
important in physics
so how does the standard model fit in
this picture because you have a local
hamiltonian
very well
yes it has a local hamiltonian that
is in three dimensions so so i don't
know the density of states
but in principle may work